ja ich wünschte es wäre hier so wie Paul
ramsheimer ist aus der Ukraine
berichtete was Corona angeht das ist
hier auch nicht mehr real wäre wir haben
heute seit heute eine
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht das
klingt sehr technisch das klingt sehr
sehr gut indirekt tatsächlich sind rund
wie jeder siebte deutsche Arbeitnehmer
Arbeits Platz Inhaber ist betroffen von
der Pflicht sich gegen kubit 19 impfen
lassen zu müssen weil er oder sie
mittelbar ein Arbeitsplatz im
Gesundheitswesen hat und das ist ein
rechter Zivilisationsbruch es ist eine
politische Gewalttat weil hier
eingegriffen wird in die körperliche
Unversehrtheit gesunder Menschen ich als
einfacher Notarzt darf Patienten nur
gegen ihren Willen behandeln unter sehr
engen Bedingungen nämlich nur dann wenn
ich den unmittelbaren Tod oder das
unmittelbare schwere leidabwände und
zwar nicht auf Hand irgendwelcher
warenvorstellungen eines Karl Lauterbach
der theoretische Möglichkeiten immer
wieder herbeifantasiert sondern ich
brauche ganz konkreten Anhalt dass er
oder sie sich selbst schädigen wird weil
er klar sagt ich bedanke mich
umzubringen oder einen dritten schädigt
nur dann darf durch diesen Menschen
zwingend behandelt zu werden und jetzt
haben wir Substanzen im Umlauf
Arzneimittel mit schweren Nebenwirkungen
die verabreicht werden zwangsweise
respektive wenn ich sie dann nicht nehme
nicht diese indirekte Zwang dann ist
mein Arbeitsplatz eben weg die
bewiesenermaßen bewiesenermaßen keinen
Dritten schützen können und auch
keinerlei Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems abwenden müssen oder
können das ist ein absoluter Kulturbruch
es ist eine vollkommene Überschreitung
aller rechtsstaatlichen Grenzen und es
ist eine politische Gewalttat die
dringend gestoppt werden muss
eine politische Gewalt hat das scheint
mir doch direkt mal zu Wolfgang Bosbach
tut sich die Regierung mit der
einrichtungsbezogen Impfpflicht
eingefallen oder ist es wie Paul
Brandenburg ausgedruckt hat ja eine
Gewalttat am Bürger
ich glaube nicht dass ich die Regierung
damit einen Gefallen tut ich würde aber
darum bitten differenziert zu
argumentieren als jemand der zweimal
geimpft ist und zweimal gebustert und
sich danach also nach vier Impfungen
infiziert hat würde ich trotzdem für das
Impfen werben weil ich so gut wie
überhaupt keine Symptome hatten
aber es ist ein Unterschied ob ich für
das Impfen Werbe und mich freiwillig
impfen lasse oder ob ich zwangsweise
durch staatliche Anordnung geimpft
werden muss es ist noch nicht lange her
da hat mich ein Repräsentant eines
großen Trägers händeringend darum
gebeten dass die Impfpflicht nicht kommt
weil er befürchtet dass es
kontraproduktiv sein könnte denn sie
betrifft ja nur Menschen die sich nicht
freiwillig lassen ich füge hinzu wenn
wir eine sterile Immunität garantieren
könnten würde ich das anders sehen aber
warum musste ich in Quarantäne als
jemand der vier Mark geimpft worden ist
doch offensichtlich weil ich
virussträger war und andere hätte
infizieren können es stimmt also nicht
dass diejenigen die geimpft sind so
geschützt sind dass sie andere nicht
infizieren können wir haben mit der
Impfpflicht die Pocken wir haben die
haben wir nun wirklich das aufgrund man
besser wissen als ich ich brauche das
jetzt mal kühn weltweit ausgerottet aber
wir haben hier keine oder leider noch
keinen Impfstoff mit dem wir eine
sterile Immunität garantieren können es
ist noch nicht lange her
er hat Herr Spahn in seiner Rolle als
Gesundheitsminister gesagt ich
garantiere Ihnen es wird keine
Impfpflicht geben auch Lauterbach selber
war einmal Kritiker der Impfpflicht
ich kann mir das nur so vorstellen dass
so eine Art Vorratsbeschluss gefasst
wird für möglicherweise eine Welle die
im Winter kommen könnte
Schlusssatz von mir das Wesentliche
Argument seit zwei Jahren war immer
keine Überlastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems warum jeder der
ernsthafte krank ist und medizinische
Behandlung braucht muss auch behandelt
werden können wir sind Gott sei Dank
trotz sehr hoher Inzidenz sind wir
meilenweit von einer Überlastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems entfernt also dieses
argumentfeld Weg als Jurist bin ich
natürlich gespannt wie Karlsruhe
entscheidend
schlimmer noch sie haben mir das
entscheidende gesagt nicht die
Freiwilligkeit ist das absolute
Stichwort das ist völlig richtig jeder
der das freiwillig möchte der soll das
Recht haben und die Möglichkeit sich
behandeln zu lassen mit diesem Impfstoff
das ist vollkommen klar aber das zweite
was sie sagten ist ja der Punkt nicht
die Überlastung des Gesundheit System
hat es so niemals gegeben nicht dieser
Herr Lauterbach hat eine unendliche
Kette von Lügen aufgetischt diese
Zeitung dieser Verlag hat ja viele davon
enttarnt und immer wieder auch betitelt
dieser Mann ist ein berufsmäßiger Lügner
und Hetzer verbreitet absolute Lügen
über angebliche Intensivbetten
Knappheiten nicht über schreckliche
Wirkung auf junge Eltern Kinder würden
jetzt die Idee ihre Eltern verlieren er
zeichnet immer wieder schlimmste
Horrorszenarien nichts davon Varial
diese Lügen sind alle aufgeflogen und
die Krönung des Ganzen erleben wir jetzt
gerade wenn man immer schaut unser
deutsches Gesundheitssystem kostet im
Jahr rund 300 Milliarden Euro das ist
eine unglaubliche Summe und 11% des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes das Argument war
immer wir haben das Geld nicht dieses
Gesundheitssystem zu retten nun ist mit
einem Finger schnipsen genau diese Summe
von 300 Milliarden Jahr aufgetaucht für
neue Waffen für die Bundeswehr für
energiepolitische Ideologien der Damen
und Herren dort in Rot-Grün aber das
Gesundheitssystem konnte angeblich nur
gerettet werden mit dieser Impfung die
ja medizinisch versagt sagen wir es ganz
ehrlich es tut mir leid auch wenn Sie
bewusst und geimpft hat gepustert hat
sind nach der Impfung also das ganze ist
ein fürchterliches Lügengebäude es gibt
kein Überlastung abzuwenden und selbst
wenn hätte man wohl offenbar auch noch
Geld gehabt das zu tun das ist eine
Katastrophe Fehler darf man das Fragen
auch
eine
Zwischenfrage nur das ist das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt das hat die
Bundesregierung selbst eingeräumt
bundesweit aber hat es denn nicht
tatsächlich Kliniken gegeben die
überlastet waren mit der Folge dass
Patienten abgewiesen werden mussten zum
Beispiel für planbare Operation oder
dass man andere Kliniken um deren
Aufnahme gebeten hat so dass es eine
partielle Belastung völlig richtig aber
da muss man auch wieder sagen das ist in
der Intensivmedizin leider tägliches
Geschäft immer zu den erkältungswellen
zu den Grippewellen zu den saisonalen
Häufungen von Infektionen haben wir
diese Überlastung ich als Notarzt bin im
Bereich Berlin Brandenburg häufig damit
beschäftigt gewesen sogenannte
sekundärverlegung zu machen das ist der
technische Terminus dafür wenn so eine
hier voll ist und wir Patienten verlegen
müssen das ist relativ normal erklärt
sich durch das bezahlungssystem im
Gesundheitswesen man kann vereinfacht
sagen eine Intensivstation muss immer
voll sein damit sie sich trägt so etwas
wie eine freie Intensivstation gibt es
nicht ansonsten fällt sie weg da ist
also immer höchstens ein oder zwei
Betten sind da frei oder werden dafür
verwendet so ist das System aufgebaut
das ist vollkommen normal andersherum
gesagt unsere Intensivstation sind seit
vielen Jahren überlastet das Personal
ist stark überlastet das ist aber alles
alt und einer der Hauptverantwortlichen
Täter für diese chronische Überlastung
ist heute Gesundheitsminister der hat
dieses System erfunden dieses did System
und ein Personalsystem einen ein
Arbeitssystem ein Schichtsystem was die
Menschen wirklich auf dem Knochen
Bremsen lässt und das dafür sorgt dass
wir Rekrutierungsprobleme haben
insbesondere bei der Pflege also die
Überlastung ist real da hat auch Corona
mit reingespielt aber Corona war eben
nicht kausal es war eine Überlastung mit
Corona aber nicht eine Belastung an
Corona ich bin ja auch eine die oft und
gerne Karl Lauterbach kritisiert hat
hier auch in der Sendung ich muss sagen
er ist aber immer wieder gekommen also
egal was wir gemacht haben er ist auch
hingekommen hat sich den Dialog gestellt
das hat mir schon Respekt abverlangt
deswegen meine Frage an dich Ralf darf
man Karl Lauterbach als Hetzer
bezeichnen wie ist Dr verbrandenburg
Garde gesagt ich wäre mit dem mit dem
Wort weil er ja ohnehin von vielen
inflationär verwendet wird etwas
sparsamer auch Franz Müntefering hat vor
Jahren schon mal gesagt es sei ziemlich
unfair Politiker immer an ihren Worten
von gestern zu messen
ja gut
das Problem was ich einfach sehe ist die
logische Lücke die sich immer mehr
Menschen
erschließt andererseits dürfen wir auch
nicht vergessen 58 Prozent sagen in
unserer letzten Umfrage vom letzten
Wochenende immer noch sie sind für eine
Impfpflicht unter anderem weil sie
selbst geimpft sind und das doof finden
das andere ist nicht sind dem kann man
aber natürlich entgegenhalten wenn wir
täglich mehr als 100.000 infizierte
haben dann ist irgendwann die impflücke
aufgebraucht das heißt also wenn
nur um diejenigen Dinge aus denen die
Infektionen sich speist die nicht
geimpft sind dann werden die nach einer
Woche alle krank gewesen das Problem ist
tatsächlich wie herausbach vierfach
geimpft und und schon wieder ein
Quarantäne die Impfung ist eine normale
Medizin sie ist eine Art virologisches
Pflaster sie wirkt nicht als das wo wir
früher Impfungen definiert haben und wir
kommen noch einmal zum Thema Einsatz
noch zu Herrn Dr Brandenburg es gibt ja
auch sie sind Mediziner es gibt viel
Kritik von Medizinern an den an den
Maßnahmen und ganz verrückt ist was ich
hier gefunden habe aus den Reihen des
Gesundheitsministeriums gibt es vom 22
februar eine ein Factsheet Fragen und
Antworten eben zu dieser
einrichtungsbezogenen impfprävention
Impfpflicht untersteht um eigentlich
zitiere jetzt um eine Eintragung und
Weiterverbreitung des Virus in diesen
Settings eben bei den Pflegepersonal zu
vermeiden ist es unerlässlich dass das
dort tät Personal vollständig geimpft
ist Ralf du hast darauf hingewiesen wir
haben jeden Tag mehr als 100.000 200.000
1260.000
infizierte also die Impfung und dazu
kommen wir gleich schützt nicht wir
brauchen ja noch Zeit für dein Thema